And uh today we should go through the
topic practical aspects of of linear
regression. So it should be uh lot less
uh theory a lot more practical practical
stuff. So the practical stuff is maybe
you already seen it in your exercises.
If you are given some example of a
distillation column where there are
multiple things which are measured like
temperatures,
pressures, sometimes some compositions
but that's not the that's not the rule.
uh and you want to find out for example
our typical example is what is a what is
a
composition
composition of some distillated or or or
bottom stream because physical chemistry
with the with the mandatory lectures is
telling us that uh these uh this should
be somehow somehow correlated. Yeah,
there are all these uh all these
equilibria which which are telling okay
if we have a if we have a mixture of two
two liquids at a given temperature
pressure everything is in equilibrium.
This temperature should indicate for
example what is the what is the the
composition and uh the problem is that
there is there is no lack of the of the
measurements. There is abundance of the
of the of the measurements. There is
more more measurements than uh actually
we have uh possible possible data. Let's
uh so let's illustrate it. Uh, of course
we are trying to we are trying to uh
work out
our
our linear regression model. This is
already in the in the prediction form.
the the columns of this of this matrix
X
well can
be sorry columns of
X can be
um temperature at the first tray
temperature at the at the second tray
pressure at the at the top pressure at
the at the bottom
um and so on and and and so and so
forth. We can also think about uh uh
having like
uh multiplications. I don't know if it
if it if it would make sense probably
this this wouldn't make sense from the
from the physical point of view. We can
also
uh also think about some I don't know
there is the standard distillate to to
feed ratio how much how much product in
the distillate we are getting how much
how much feed we are we are
feeding feeding
in and uh so there can be any type
of nonlinear transformation of this of
this data of course any other things e
to the power of something of some
temperature if you remember arenous law
that's that that's that's quite common
and uh yeah so the question is how to
how to how to decide about uh about
these terms uh
slightly well very similar but slightly
The maybe uh less complicated version is
uh if we are trying to trying to build a
model which is a polomial. Yeah. So
let's say we have some P 0 and maybe
only only in in in one
variable we can we can
do some polomial
expansion to basically to basically uh
whichever degree. Of course this is this
gets even more complicated. If we for
example would have two variables then we
get some cross productducts stuff like
that.
So again and you have you might have
already already faced it is I remember
your physical chemistry labs are usually
stopping at some at some linear uh well
this linear linear term and uh maybe
sometimes this quadratic term then you
can analyze by some means uh how how
well this
uh this or that uh polomial would uh
would
fit. Uh so the question is how to how to
go about this? How to how to select
something something
reasonable? Uh we
already what what we have finished last
time with was uh we we studied this uh
correlation concept.
So now we can we can say whether whether
it's uh this this sort of data in the
matrix X or whether it's this sort of
data whether whether these
uh independent variables would be uh
would be
correlated uh and uh close to this
correlation is the concept of
dependence.
Now comes the question
uh what does it mean if something is is
dependent should be correlated and if
something is correlated should be should
be dependent yes or no in other words
should we just write like this
double-sided implication. So if if uh
something if and only if something is
correlated then it is also dependent and
it's dependent then it's then it's
correlated or
not what was the example that we were
that we were finishing correlation
doesn't mean it's
Mhm. Yeah, we can we can also call this
causality. Okay. So, so then
the double-sided implication holds or or
we should rewrite it in some way.
I
would say it's not implication like
dependence is correlation but the
correlation is independent.
[Music]
And I and I deleted it the other way.
Yes, correct. So if uh if there is a
dependence uh among some variables then
we should we should see it in the in the
correlation coefficient. It would imply
correlation. Uh correlation doesn't
imply that there is a dependence. If you
recall our last example, the number of
students uh at this faculty going abroad
or coming from abroad, well uh they were
pretty much pretty much correlated but
this correlation was only caused uh by
the covid pandemics which uh which made
all these numbers drop at the same time.
So they were dropping at the same time
but it didn't mean that uh few uh less
students coming to the to this faculty
would uh would imply that there is less
students also coming
out. Okay.
[Music]
Um so when when we are talking about the
about this uh this correlation when we
spot some correlation among the among
some var among some independent
variables yeah so if x1 and x2 whatever
whatever they are temperatures pressures
and so on if they are correlated that's
like
actually an unwanted situation
situation
unwanted unwanted
let's let's detail it uh detail it next
but uh actually for some whatever
variable let's say x1 and and y well the
correlation is actually welcome right
because well we are trying to to make
sense of of a Y based on the based on
the on the data X. Yeah. So we would
measure some X let's say temperature and
we want to to correlate it to some uh to
some uh desired variable that we want to
that we want to predict for example for
example composition. So there should be
should be some some correlation
otherwise otherwise
this parameter can have even completely
random value
wouldn't wouldn't correspond to the to
the
reality. So yes here the here the
correlation
is is desired.
Let's try to to plot this uh this
unwanted uh unwanted situation. Let's
say that we
are that we are building a
model which
has just two parameters, two two inputs,
two independent
variables and uh and we didn't check for
the for the correlation. We actually
don't know
uh we actually don't know that our data
x1 and x2 would look maybe maybe like
this. Yeah, we we just disregard we
build build our our matrix x and we and
we and we go
ahead. Uh maybe this already means that
there is some hidden relationship. Let's
say I don't know x1 is k * k *
x2. This can be a natural phenomenon
like the two two temperatures at the
distillation column at the uh stages or
trays which are close to each other they
would be very very much uh very much
correlated or it can be also a problem
of experimentation. We are trying to
build a correlation between some
composition, temperature and pressure.
And for some reason we decide uh and
this is not a arbitrary example. It
happens happens many many times and for
some reason we we would
just just decide well okay if we let's
do several experiments and whenever we
increase the temperature we will incre
increase the pressure. Yeah. So we this
is these are our independent variables.
We set up the experiment temperature
pressure and then we measure some uh
dependent variable that we want to that
we want to find uh this this sort of
model for um yeah let's see what what
are the what are the consequences. So we
can just easily plug this uh
relationship. We don't know but we we
don't we don't know about it uh always
but we can assume that it exists. If it
exists then what? Let's let's plug it
like P1 K * X2. Yeah. Replacing the the
X1 variable
and and we keep our
X2. We can now we can now grab the terms
with x2 to
[Music]
together. And this basically means well
there is only one parameter that we
should be looking for and uh whatever
whatever parameters p1 and p2 we will
actually estimate they will be already
already correlated to uh to go close to
the to the true value of this of this uh
of this bracket. The problem is that
then this p1 and and p2 can be
completely arbitrary because uh let's
say
the in reality we should find that this
is equal to three. Yeah. Let's say just
for just for the example sake that the k
is equal to one. So well what are the
combinations of P1 plus P2 being equal
equal to
three? What what numbers P1 and P2 can
take such that they are equal to three.
All numbers
all your numbers.
Yes. Just some example something easy.
One and two. One and two.
One and a half. One and a half. One and
a half. and what the same
not like this okay uh equal to three I
just I just chose that such that we
don't have always just ones and ones and
zeros but also minus5 and uh what do I
need eight would work
so all these values of p1 and p2 can be
result of of our of our regression and
uh well if they should represent and
some physical um values, quantities,
parameters. It doesn't doesn't seem to
be uh to be to be re reasonable to
uh to have this additional degree of
freedom. What we can also easily imagine
imagine this situation. Think about
think about this. That's my attempt for
a for a 3D plot. So we have x1
x x1 x2
uh
which let's say have
this have this
correlation and now for each of each of
these uh combinations x1 x2 well we will
measure our dependent uh dependent
variable. So our our y our
data something maybe would look like
let's say
our now I'm hitting the limits of my of
my 3D plotting. Let's just try something
and hope it it works out.
So let's say that the real function the
ground through that we don't know that
we try to learn from the data looks like
this uh this plane but
now if we take the if we take the
measurements well this these
measurements for X1 and X2 we will
measure at the first experiment the
value of some composition
Why? Then
we continue then well also our our
experimental data would would would look
like this.
Uh and our model is uh well P1 and P2 is
basically some kind of a normal vector
to this uh to this plane. So this is
what we are trying to learn. But what
what's the what's the problem with this?
What's what's the can you can you sense
any any
problematic
point? Is it uh fixed or is it uh is it
possible to find just one plane that
would go that would share share this
this line? There are multiple there are
multiple of them, right? Uh we can
basically if we if we
take if we basically take this line as
some axis of of rotation, we can
basically fit any any any sort of a sort
of a model very very easily. we
wouldn't we wouldn't uh notice our
regression would would go would go as
usual. Yeah, you can
uh easily compare it with the with the
example where our points are
uh better better
distributed. So our
Yeah, our points no no no no longer
follow a line and now it's quite hard to
to to wiggle this uh this this plane
such that uh our um our s such that this
plane our our model would very uh would
would go away from our data points. Here
it's here it's very easy around this
around this axis of of rotation. So
that's the that's the uh problematic
part. So that's why this uh situation is
uh unwanted. It's uh it's good to tackle
this situation as soon as possible.
Building a coariance matrix, doing some
correlations
and and uh get rid of the of the
variables that are that are correlated
in the independent
um and to to have x1 and x2 as
independent as uh as
possible. Okay.
So let's now maybe go to this
uh this very simple situation where we
where we are just building a polomial
model just one one
variable
and let's say
our the data we have uh we have measured
would look like this. So that's our
independent variable. This is uh first
our our data points. What would you
suggest to be uh model how what would be
the order? What would be the complexity
of the model to fit this data?
Quadratic. Why do you say so? Because
kind of kind of turns.
Okay. Any other
linear can be also
There's almost unlimited ways to
describe it. Unlimited. Yeah. Unlimited.
I didn't hear the word. Ways. Oh, like
we can use any order. Exactly. Exactly.
Yeah. So, if we try if we try the the
linear one, well, doesn't look very bad.
It's might be might be
the might might might work out the the
data even even look like okay they can
be uh from they they can just uh the
error of our prediction can follow uh
close to normal distribution. So it
seems that we we just have a a problem
with the with the noisy sensor. Uh maybe
if we if we see the quadratic fit. Okay.
Well, maybe from from this this point
this point up they are fine here.
Something bad bad happened. Uh maybe our
our sensor even even had had a
malfunction.
Um we can go we can do whatever whatever
way. So that was linear quadratic. Now
this is octic fit. So I took a 8 degree
polomial. Doesn't it look lovely? It's
just passing almost through any data
point.
Yeah. Is is is is that the that the
correct one? What do you what do you
think? Okay. Good good good observation
good observation that it might it might
go go bad if we if we try to try to
extrapolate okay so let's try to
extrapolate let's try to extrapolate our
our linear model so what happens here uh
from 0 to one was where we uh where
where the data that I was showing
showing showing showing before this is
our linear model and from from uh from
from the point one uh farther we didn't
adapt the the model. We just observed
the observed the data and uh and we
extrapolated our
model. It looks apparently bad, right?
But it's not the not the end of the
world. So first first message is
oops too much too much zoomed in.
Whoops.
Still do not extrapolate. And
if this one is this one is still still
good. So linear models can can be
extrapolated. This is already I mean too
far. Yeah, we
almost our model has seen only data from
this interval and we are basically
doubling the the the size of the
interval. So if we just extra
extrapolated a
bit then then we would we would still be
okayish but even a bit but already
already very nicely observed if our our
octic fit would just completely ignore.
Of course, it tries to fit all the all
the data points. It tries to actually
fit all the noise. We don't want to fit
the noise. Uh we don't care about the
about fitting the noise. We want to fit
the the information that is in the data
and it will just just nicely nicely
escape. Uh so what is the what is the
remedy and you have already already seen
seen this in
your in your in your exercises is to
um is to well of course try to get the
data in the in the full range of uh
where the where the model should be
valid where you want to where you want
to use it and uh because well
what what's what's the what's the point
here? Maybe maybe I I fitted the the
data for some normal operation and then
I just started to use the the model and
uh in small bit of time uh there there
was a change in the in the operation in
the in the in the plant. Yeah. uh
different oil came to the came to the
refinery.
Uh a different supplier of some of some
chemical is is uh delivering uh
different different sort of a uh raw raw
material and immediately your boss tells
you well your model is It doesn't
doesn't work. Yeah. So how to how to
avoid this? How do we know that we have
to uh feed
the data with
the polinomial curve.
Oh well, you you you you don't know but
but you can you can you can try it as as
one of the one of the guesses. Uh why?
Because uh you you learned in the
mathematics uh that uh the there is this
tailor expansion that basically any
nonlinear function you can uh you can
try to approximate with the with a
polomial and polomials basically are
good approximators. Yeah, you can also
also do uh there are but this is
advanced concepts like uh if you spot in
your in your polomial model
certain where is it if you if you spot
in this in this model certain certain
patterns then you can try uh think about
uh how uh how nonlinear is the is the
relationship that you are trying to
trying to predict or maybe what is the
shape of the of the function whether
it's exponential whether it's whether
it's logarithm
yeah but well it's a usually some some
some good good correlation if you or
some good uh good practice if you don't
really have an idea yeah I mean we are
giving we are using here the examples of
distillation column for which we have
the feeling so that you have a feeling
but if you are just estimating well the
uh price of the of the stock uh of the
price of the of the Bitcoin. It's it's
quite quite hard to to to know all the
all the inputs to to know what is the
what is the physical reality reality
behind
uh so also a good question would be how
do I know beforehand what is the region
of validity of my model well uh it's not
not always easy to know uh but well you
are hoping for the best and if uh if the
situation with the extrapolation that we
that we saw above uh would uh would
occur. You can either retrain your your
model by again collecting the data and
so on or there are some other uh
techniques uh which will just try to
based on the observed data points like
in the live situation when the model is
already working and predicting that
could take the recent data points and
try slightly push some parameters of the
model. We will we will discuss that
uh in some in some other lecture. And uh
then the idea would be
to kind
of try to simulate the situation that we
will start to use our our model that we
put our our model to be uh live and
doing doing the predictions by having a
sort of a so so-called validation data.
The so the idea is I have several
experiments and I split the data to the
training and validation. The training
data would be would be used for
calculating the the values of the
parameters and validation data would be
used to check whether whether the
uh value of uh whether whether the
prediction error is still still okayish
whether it is at least similar to what
the the training data would uh would
suggest.
We'll get back to this. Let's just uh
let's just try
to write it down. Let's say we have a
um this technique is act actually has a
has a name which is called cross
validation.
So in
the in the cross validation we we split
the data
uh
into training
training
data
validation
data and testing.
[Music]
Ts. The idea
is
that we have the whole pool of our of
our data points and we do and we do the
split. We will keep some of the data
typically something like 20% but it it
varies for the for the testing. This
will be the data that we sort of put in
the in the black black box in a in a
vault before we start to do anything
with our with
our with uh with with the rest of the
data before starting to to train the
model. They will be used just for the
final assessment. they are the final
stamp like if I try if I start to use uh
my model in the daily production of a of
factory uh then this will be the this
will be the performance
um the rest of the data will be split
again I don't know 50 to 30
uh between the training
training and and
validation. How will how how will this
how will this work? Let's
say that
uh
well we will be now choosing different
models either different orders of the
polomial linear or quadratic or we can
also bring more and more terms
temperature at the first tray,
temperature at the fifth ray and so on
and and so forth. So basically we will
be getting more and more complex complex
models. Let's denote it with this uh
number of parameters uh uh MP. Yeah,
because each of these will have uh in
its own
parameter and uh well what hap what
would happen with the let's let's put
them give them some some colors uh
training data
validation and
maybe maybe testing. So what would
happen for
our for our our training data? Well,
this is the situation with the first
doing linear fit, then quadratic, then
cubic and so on until until the octic
fit. Let's say we
uh we
[Music]
see we are observing some performance of
the of the model. Let's say it will be
the root mean squared of the of the
prediction
error. Well,
our what was the training yellow one?
Well, what we can typically observe for
the for the for the training data, the
more terms we we add. Well, the our our
model is based on optimization. It tries
to please us. It tries to minimize the
prediction error. So uh even though
uh even though uh the reality maybe our
our uh best possible model has just
complexity of three parameters well we
we won't have a chance seeing in the in
the training data what happens. Yeah
this is the situation where was that was
our great optic fit. Yeah, if we would
calculate the RMSSE and and compare
compare with here, well, this this this
one will will be will be definitely much
much much higher because the optic model
is just fitting the noise.
So
our if we if we have the if we have the
the testing data at at our at our hand
of course we would we would see a
different different trend. So of course
they the fit won't be as good but uh
maybe we would be able to to see this uh
badness of the of the octic fit or of of
some more complex model. So we would we
would observe that there is some best
order of the model best complexity of
the of the model at at this point.
And basically the whole idea is that we
of course don't have the testing data.
We put them in the in the black box. But
we can simulate this uh this testing
data with the with the with the
validation data that basically should go
should go the in a in a similar similar
way.
Why would
uh yeah why why would we just uh just
playing with the why would we just keep
the keep the validation
data? It's it's it's because well they
are part of the part of the data that uh
that we can use for whatever uh whatever
decision about the order of the model.
Good. Does it make sense? Did also
Rashto explain it somehow this way or
intuitively this this this way during
the
exercises? Okay, first question. Does it
make sense?
I guess you witnessed all all this this
this already at your at your exercises.
Of course when
uh of course when we are talking about
this RMSE there are some other um
assessment criteria. So let's maybe go
through them.
our assessment
[Music]
criteria. Of course, you already you
already know it know this because you've
seen it in your in your exercises root
mean squared
error. So, RMSSE or root mean squared
prediction error. Yeah, sometimes there
is even even this P uh
pronounced um
How do we how do we calculate it?
Anybody
[Music]
recalls mean is here. We can start start
from here. Root mean squared error. It's
very uh how to how how to say it like a
very nomen omen uh uh not not definition
but the but the but the name. So we
first need the root. So it's square
root then we take the mean. So 1 /
n sum
from one to n. And what are we what are
we summing? We are summing squares and
squares of the of the error. So we have
a
square and we are and our prediction
error is the difference between what we
measured and what we what we
predict. Well,
it's it's uh very easy if you remember
just RMSSE. You can you can make it up.
Okay, that's the that's the one that's
the first one and very very popular one
I also like and probably you will you
will recall it uh and it's very much
very much used uh so-called
[Music]
coefficient coefficient of
determination don't even recall the
Slovak
name. Where is
my
determination? But you will probably
recognize if I say if I say this is the
famous R squared. You remember seeing R
squared when you yeah when you were
trying to uh in some in some lab when
you were trying to say oh I I did this
did this fit there was some standard
deviation of a prediction error
something like
RMSSE and uh usually also the R squar
value was trying to indicate something.
Um do you uh recall by any chance
basically how it how it works?
Usual usually you are just given the
given the the the formula
it's
like it's
perfect
and zero is like it doesn't make sense
at all. Mhm.
Um yeah what what does it tries to tries
to determine this coefficient
coefficient is tries it uh it it tries
to determine whether the model that you
build is better than just doing a simple
fit let's say by a constant. Let's let's
draw it. Uh let's say that this is how
my how my data looks.
Just copy this.
Copy. I no I forgot how to copy. Ah, now
I know
it. And basically we want to we want to
compare whether our how good is our
model and how would be how good would be
the model if I just just fit the data
with a constant.
So this is it. This is it behind the
behind the R squared value. How to put
it in sort in some in some formula?
Well, there is this there is a one minus
and now
we so what should what should happen? I
want let's let's take for example RMSSE
or maybe we can just take the the sum of
squares that's that's uh completely
enough because the rest of the terms
would cancel out so this one if this one
is small and this one is this one is
large small large we are getting we are
getting close to close to one and this
is exactly how it how it works. So in
the numerator we have
this sum of squares of our model of our
prediction prediction error. Yeah. And
what we do what we use in the
denominator is k= 1 yk. And well how to
how to fit this constant? Well, that's
our that's one of our uh lectures from
from before. Well, we can just take the
average of the of the y's average of our
of our data
points.
Um usually takes this values between
zero and and one basically by
construction. Sometimes it can happen
that it uh that it can be
negative. If it's if it's negative for
some reason then uh pay attention there
was something wrong there there is some
error with the with with fitting the
model. Yeah. If it would be negative it
would mean it would mean what that uh
that the uh that our our model maybe
maybe it goes like this. Yeah. Maybe
there was there was some some some error
when when when doing the the calculation
calculation of the
model. Okay.
Ah,
another maybe close to close to visual
very very nicely visual visual
visualizable is this uh parity plot
which you already which you have already
already seen
uh we started with it in the in the
first lecture. The the idea is well uh
of course these kind of uh these kind of
plots uh if we can if we can do them uh
it's fine what what better what better
assessment uh you you can get but well
they will work if we have one
independent variable maybe if we have
two independent variables we can get the
3D plot but if we have uh more of the
more of them 10 it's already quite hard
to uh to see how the how the model
performs. So for for that we can do this
parity or can even call it correlation
plot of
the of the let's say our prediction
versus our our
measurement.
So if our prediction our best model we
we
found the best model model we we found
would be would be good then what we
would observe is
basically this uh diagonal line which
means what
the the value that our model would
predict predict is exactly the value is
exactly the value that our data
observed. Of course, we cannot uh expect
to be to be
uh completely sitting on the line. There
is still the still measurement noise.
But this kind of situation if uh if if
our predictions versus our measured data
lie next next to this line is uh is is
quite quite quite okay very very much
desirable. Uh what are the possibilities
of how this plot could could look like
in in the
different different
setting?
Um
no one possibility one one probable
situation would would look like this
that
um of course you maybe have done
everything right. Uh basically what
happens in this in this situation? Uh if
I um I I predict something but the what
I what I what I what I predicted uh has
a corresponding measurement that is
somewhere that is above this predicted
value. But it it at least at least has a
has a good trend. Yeah. If I if I
predict a larger number then also our
the measurements correspond to the to
the larger number. The problem that uh
the that is signified by by this plot is
uh basically we either didn't select uh
the correct correct model which
basically means we are missing some of
the independent variables. Yeah,
something is dependent on pressure and
we completely disregarded the pressure.
So we we we are missing this
information. That's how that's uh for
what our model suffers from. So
missing regressor or
missing missing input to the model.
Another interesting situation is where
it where is if uh if this party plot
looks sort of sort of okayish at some
some parts and then it starts to somehow
somehow deviate. Yeah. So like a
combination of uh of of these two these
two
situations again might be might be might
be similar reason or the reason might
also easily be that there is some
nonlinear relationship that we that we
didn't didn't include in in our
assumptions.
some
[Music]
nonlinear
behavior. So what I uh what I recommend
is uh when you are uh when you are about
to uh find the find the or
Train train a model. Don't rely just on
RMSSE. Check the R squared. Check the
check the parity plot. It's always
different inside for different maybe
candidate candidate
models. Okay.
[Music]
Another interesting interesting point uh
might be to to see to calculate the
confidence intervals.
confidence intervals of the parameters
of a of a model.
Um
why why would it be why would it be
reasonable? This maybe applies to the
situation where we have a where we have
a lot of lot of data. So the confidence
interval the statistics basically works
very well. But uh we can very easily in
very easily um get rid or even avoid the
situation like situation situations like
this. Um if
our octic model or whatever whatever
polomial
model whatever polomial model would
uh would
be so to say overfitted. There is uh one
more parameter that just tries to fit
the noise. Then also our confidence
interval that will that will tell us uh
basically the the probability the
probable range of this of this value. It
it would basically contain zero which is
a which is a good indication of uh of
this that basically says with the same
probability level my model can live
without the x cubed parameter without
the parameter p3.
uh how to how to get to the to the
confidence uh confidence
intervals. Well, we already know how to
do this when we did the very simple
linear regression just with the just for
one one slope. Um how to do this in
the in in general? Um it will again has
have it will again have to do with some
with some matrices. Basically we want to
find out
uh some coariance matrix of of
parameters. If you recall our coariance
matrix of
uh of the of the data x looked something
like this. We we wanna we want to do
some something similar. So we w to do
the average this expected value we
already we already used
for now this is a does this work? Yes
this yeah because this this this should
be the matrix. So P * P transpose should
give us
matrix. So
our vector P is MP * 1. Yeah, it's the
column vector. Our vector our vector P
transpose
is 1 by
MP. So in developing this matrix we
should basically get
information about each parameter and uh
its
uh standard deviation its its
statistics. Yeah. So the matrix
discoverance matrix at the end would
look very similarly to our coariance
matrix for the for the data. What we
what we had here? We had the uh what was
it? Variance of x1
x1 x1 x1 coariance
x1 x1 x2 and and and so on. And this
matrix would
look would look the same would work the
same
way. Yeah. Come here. We actually don't
need
this double
index. Yeah.
So we want to find how how much the
parameter P1 based on our measurements
uh is uh can uh can can spread its uh
its its values how uncertain this
parameter
[Music]
is. Yeah.
uh how to how to build this this matrix
should be pretty easy. We just take the
well we know our parameters that's
our nice formula xrpose x xrpose y and
there is a inverse. So basically we can
just uh we can just plug this p into
this p * p
transpose would look messy in the in the
beginning but yeah we'll we'll work it
out. So let's plug it in. Our VP is the
expectation of so our parameter
P. Now we use the
definition XRpose X inverse XRpose Y.
Good. And now we need now we use the the
transpose of P. How would the transpose
of P look like?
Mhm. Y transpose. Yeah. We
basically transpose all of these and we
completely flip the flip the order.
Exactly. So ypose then x and then well
we don't have anything to worry about
because this matrix is is symmetric
the the coariance matrix is symmetric
also its inverse has to be has to be
symmetric.
Okay. H doesn't look very easy. But we
just need to recall some something that
if
we what we what we just got here the y
transpose is nothing else than some
again some some coariance uh coariance
matrix of our of our data which would
mean well if
our if our data
are in
the in the
pandent what does it mean that if I take
one experiment and the second experiment
the second experiment will not be
influenced by the first experiment yeah
the the y is only the value of what I'm
measuring only uh only depends on the on
the independent variables on uh
temperatures pressures.
Yeah. Which basically means that
well we will we will just have
the the variance of the basically
measurement measurement error. So how
much how much
our measured data are of the of their
mean mean value. And if this if this
measurement noise would be uh would be
consistent so would not would not change
would be would be constant then
basically our our matrix would look just
like this. Of course it can be can be
much bigger based on the based on the
number of
data
independent constant noise.
But this means that we can actually
simplify this
expression and just use
the variance of the of the measurement
error and some identity
matrix. So we can
basically just plug this in. So our
identity matrix would just do do
basically nothing and we can pluck the
uh pull the variance of the of
the of the measurement error out of this
expectation. So that
means just
say sigma sigma square and we have
here already bunch of similar terms they
will they will
simplify
nicely. What do you think? What can we
what can we simplify here?
Mhm. With what can we do with
it? So there is matrix A and there is
matrix A inverse. Right? So they they
they they just they just can cancel out
or they uh become the unit matrix. So
our our
final sorry our final expression is just
looking
like xrpose x.
Yeah. This is the variance of the of the
par of the parameters.
somewhere.
Yes. But I mean if we don't write it,
it's this is already a matrix. Yeah. So
if I if I just write the square matrix
here, it doesn't doesn't change
anything. Yeah. Okay.
Yeah. Uh it's it's is it's different
different here. Yeah. Here the one.
Ah no. Okay. Uh
Huh? Let me
think. Should be there,
right? I can do the
should be there. How is
it? Why would it
[Music]
disappear? Because
basically no I don't know why how how
would it how would it disappear so it
should be
there n I don't know I'm missing
something but uh well before before we
know any anything more I will I will
check it and u and correct it maybe next
time.
Um the the
the interesting observation is
uh
well this matrix will will tell us
basically how how uncertain are our
parameter values. Of course it should be
uh it should be directly corresponding
to how large is is our noise. Yeah. If
our noise is large, our uncertainty in
the parameters is big. A second one is
is is even more interesting because well
the the coariance matrix the values of
independent variables it's that's our
our choice that's our our experiment. We
are designing an experiment. We also
already know that we shouldn't design
experiment such that our independent
data points are uh are on the on the
line. actually if they are on the line
there will be already problem with the
with the inverse here. Um and
uh also uh there is a similar
observation to what me to what we made
when we were doing the estimation of a
constant. More measurements we we take
the more this this matrix would uh would
grow and less because there is the
inverse less smaller will be will be our
uh our error in the in the
parameters. Um good let's try to let's
try to visualize it. Uh if we have
our basically
If
we we can very easily treat the
parameter P again as a as a random
random number or random vector. We might
have calculated maybe some estimated
value of the parameters and now we even
have the even have a
uh coariance
matrix. But well we have seen this in
our statistics whenever we describe
something with this two
parameters one is vector now and one is
one is a matrix. So we can build some uh
some
gausian probability distribution
function. So let's say that we that we
attempt this here. So the probability
distribution function of of our
parameters now in
the multi-dimensional settings
uh if you recall the scalar case what
did we have there? We had
uh square t of 2
pi and
sigma.
Yes. And we had the exponential function
x -
x bar / 2 sigma sigma square. Yeah.
Something like something like this.
uh this multi-dimensional uh variant
will be very very very very similar. We
just need to take care about few things.
One thing is that our 2 pi has now
exponent and that's this normalization
constant now in several variables.
uh
our our standard deviation. Well, what
was it in the scalar case? We just took
a square root of the of the variance. We
again take a square root of the of the
variance. But we need to
get but we also need to get a single
number. So we take a matrix square root
and we take a determinant to actually
this will again be a be a scalar number
because it's the probability
density that could work. And what
happens with with this
one? Well minus what? P min - P hat
transpose
VP
inverse now there should be 1/2
somewhere minus
12 P minus P
hat not nothing else than than than just
the vector matrix product
uh uh product the rather of our of our
scalar expression. There should be
square
here.
Oops. Yeah. So this is a quadratic form.
Well, instead of division with the very
coariance matrix, we we just use the use
the
inverse. Okay, you suffered from this
math. So, it's time to show you some
pictures. Let's see the pictures. Let's
bring them somewhere
up. Where are
we? Okay.
Okay. So this is basically how our our
multi-dimensional
uh PDF would look like. It's still this
gausian gausian curve. There is a there
there is this uh this sort of a sort of
a bell. And uh if we for example uh look
at this uh from the from the side of of
P1 and P2 it's it's it works quite nice
because well let's say that we are
looking at the at this from the side of
P1. I usually uh use this. You take a
torch, you shut down the lights, and you
you light the light light the torch. And
the shadow that this hill would would
project well, it would it would look
something like
this. Yeah, there will be this there
will be this
uh gausian bell recovered. Basically
from this multi-dimensional picture you
can very easily get the onedimensional
information and that's that's quite
nice. That's not like it's uh it's it's
granted or or it's that that obvious
that we have this nice mathematics. Same
would go for the for
the for the parameter parameter P B P B
P B P B P B P B P B P B P B P B P B P B
P B P B P B P B P B P B P B P B P2.
Yeah, we can from from this shine a
light and and and the shadow would would
give us this uh information about about
the
P2. It's uh also not
uh not a coincidence that uh well I
visualized here this sort of a sort of
rings. Yeah, it's like a like a level
sets. If I say okay I cut the PDF at the
level of
0.002 then I basically have this ring uh
that rules them all. How how would it
how would it look in the
we see like there are different steeps
on one and the other side there are
different
just repeat the word I steeps like what
is steep
like slope adjective
sayations
Okay. So, okay. The Mhm.
from from which one? From uh Yes. I
mean Mhm. Mhm. You
can that's what you what what what you
are what you are saying is the this
curve. Yeah. I on purpose didn't plot a
curve that would be like nicely
symmetric. Of course it it exists but on
purpose I I I plot the curve where well
if we take now these rings and we just
uh make them make them flat do the do
the contour plot well what can we
observe the spread of the P1 is much
larger than the spread of the of the of
the P2. So if this was the result of our
uh of our uh regression, yeah, our
regression gave us the the uh the point
P uh P hat. So the uh most probable
value of the parameter, but also gave us
the coariance matrix through which we
actually uh
got got these uh level sets. Then then
we then we can then then this indicates
how much how much uncertainty we have in
which parameter and it's clear that
uncertainty in parameter B1 is
uh is much much larger basically
the this thing we have we have here now
I switch the colors ah that wasn't
So
our uncertainty in in P1 and uncertainty
in in in
P2. Yeah, it's obvious that our data and
also our model told us uh told us uh
told told us more specific more accurate
information to estimate parameter P2
than than the parameter parameter
P1. If you are asking yourself why there
are these different rings and and bands
uh or actually this ellipses well the
reason is is very very simple like we
did in the scalar case. In the scalar
case, we uh we took our
um quadratic form of our of this of this
of this exponent. So so the quadratic
form we took the x² and said even if we
have more x if you if even if you have
sum of x squared then this would obey
the k square distribution. The similar
thing we can we can do here and we can
take
our P minus P hat
transpose VP
inverse and say that this is
uh this is going to
be distributed as a T square
distribution with the NP number of
parameters. mters and how to how to get
this ellipse. I think you tried uh you
either tried plotting a plotting an
ellipse uh in one of the exercises or
you will or you will do it
today.
So if we now take the the quantile of
the of the of the k square k square
distribution. This is what we already
already done when we were trying to find
the the confidence interval for the
estimation of a of a constant. Then
basically this is nothing else than the
than the equation uh equation of an
ellipse. Probably I will I will get to
it get to it next time. how to how to
plot this because yeah we have 15
minutes and probably it won't be won't
be
enough. Yeah, but believe me this is an
equivalent of the uh of saying uh p1
squar + b2 squared is equal to r². That
would be that would be just the just the
circle, right? Like x² + y² is equal r².
That's a equation of a of a circle. And
uh now we do what? Now we do its matrix
variant. And this guy here where I
forgot to put the minus one would serve
as
a would serve as
uh would have it have its purpose. It's
it's hard to uh hard to say now.
Yeah. Yeah. It basically goes into this
uh um Yeah. If you recall
the high school ellipse, the high school
ellipse looked like this. Yes. Uh where
we had
the the A was
the length of one semiaaxis. B was the
length of another semiaaxis. So they
will be hidden in this matrix.
Basically there will be nothing
else than the than the rad of of the of
the confidence intervals. But this
matrix is is also also tilted or um uh
this this ellipse is is also kind of
kind of rotated. So that's what we can
get from the from the from the other
other elements of from from this
matrix.
Um okay let's
see let's see whether I forgot something
something important of course with the
the best indication
uh if we recover our confidence interval
if the interval if the confidence
interval contains zero
Oh, then this is a this is a warning
warning sign. Yeah. Let's say that your
uh that
your regression ends up with the with
the confidence interval let's say minus
one minus one two. Yeah. What? Whatever
95%
confidence confidence
interval this is a raised raised hand uh
or uh raised warning sign red alert.
Well, all this all the values between
minus one and and two are 95% uh percent
probable. So also is the also is the
zero. So it's
a you should you should start thinking
uh can my model live without without
this parameter because obviously well it
can be that this uh that this parameter
is either uh not observable. Yeah,
linear dependence or our data do not
reveal enough of of this parameter or
basically this parameter is bringing to
the model some variable that has no uh
no correlation, no no causal effect,
nothing with the
um with the variable in question.
Okay, if this is sort of
uh sort of clear, I want
to maybe just briefly mention at the end
with the help help of some picture
pictures
some component some interesting
uh interesting method that uh pops up
very very very very frequently in the in
the in the data data anal analysis.
Basically P PCA is something the whole
world knows and uses as one of the first
methods. uh where let's imagine a
situation let's do it by by example
let's imagine this sort of a this sort
of a of a situation
uh we
are now not not doing uh not dealing
with any distillation column anything we
are trying to process some images and uh
we have different images what is it So
10 x 10. So 100 100 images. By the way,
this is Steven Tyler here. George Bush.
Another George
Bush. Maybe you can spot some somebody
somebody else famous. Robbie
Williams. Yeah.
Um and so we have
uh 100 data points.
Oops. Yeah. Okay, we have uh 100 data
points and uh well how many how many
variables uh do we have? How many
uh if if we want to if we want to encode
this image, how this how this image is
encoded?
Yes. Okay. So let's say uh they are I
don't know 400 pixels each. There are
more but yeah. So if we have 400 pixels
each pixel hund square per one picture
probably. Mhm. Mhm. Yeah. But what what
what does it mean a pixel? So it will be
like uh they are black and white images.
So they the the value let's let's say
every every point in one picture every I
cannot zoom cannot zoom more every every
point in on one picture. Ah this is too
much zoomed
in every point on a on a picture has a
value between let's say zero and one
zero means black one means white. Yeah.
So we
actually have uh 100 data points may
maybe okay let's say thousands yeah
let's let's just do it in in in order
maybe we have 10,000
variables so our matrix X
actually lives in a world uh we have
only 100
observations and we have
10,000 different values that can change.
Yeah, this is a different situation than
for example you are you you've seen in
the exercises like the distillation
column we have maybe 20 different
sensors and we can s and we have a
thousand thousand times uh gathered the
the value from this from these sensors.
This m might become a problem. Let's say
we want to do some sort of a some sort
of a prediction model which means uh how
would the prediction model uh look like?
We we have one parameter per one pixel.
So we have one par P1 we have P2 until
we have P P
10,000* X
10,000. So we want to learn 10,000 uh
10,000 uh parameters but well just out
of out of 100 data points that wouldn't
work. Yeah, because uh the simple
situation uh if I want to want to just
learn one line, I need two points. Yeah,
I need I have uh two parameters. I need
at least two points. Now I have 10,000
parameters. So 10,000 lines. I need at
least 10,000 data points. So what to do?
This is where the the the principal
component analysis comes in. And the
principal component analysis is a
technique which will
uh let's put it like
this. Okay, that wouldn't
work. It will just try to observe and
do do some do some statistics.
And so the principal component analysis
was run here and it constructed uh 2 4 6
36 faces. Uh so the these are the most
probable combinations most probable but
also independent combinations of the of
the pixels given the given the the the
data set given given these 100 images.
Yeah.
So now we only have uh this is basically
saying uh uh yeah you
[Music]
can you can see
that this this first image here yeah
it's it's just it's just saying it's
it's quite probable quite likely that
many of the of the pixels are the same
color. It doesn't say uh which which
exact color they are. It's just uh they
they sh they share almost the same
color. Basically this one is trying to
say well what is the background color on
on this on these
images and uh these guys here now become
our it's kind of new it's new variables
x1 x2 until x 36 and our new prediction
model is can then maybe let's let's call
them x tilda
our our prediction model based on this
can now just uh very easily live with
this with these 36 parameters. So, not a
100 uh sorry, what was it? 10,000 not
the 10,000
uh pixels information, but only only 36
combinations. And uh well, here you can
here you can see how the how the images
were were reconstructed back. Of course,
this uh Steven Tyler uh stay is is
visible here with his mouth full of
teeth. There was the George Bush. Don't
know whether you can recognize it from
the from the beamer. Uh what can you
say? It's maybe not that easy to now
recognize. Yeah, this the it's
definitely an approximation. Yeah. Yeah.
Here here the people are much more
recognizable. But for example, if you
are just living in this in this data set
and you want to tell your system wants
to tell Steven Tyler and George Bush
apart, this is this is enough. And
uh uh we we we got we got something uh
something working. We didn't need to fit
10,000 parameters where these parameters
would be. Most of them would have a zero
confidence interval. Yeah. So this is
the uh sketchy uh visualization of the
of the principal component analysis. The
math is relatively easy. I I can I can
show you show you next time. Any
questions to
this? Okay.